if this is your first game by from
software then you've got a lot of
learning to do and if you've been
playing from Souls games for the last
six years then you've got a lot of
learning to forget we're all really
beginners here because while blood-borne
might feel familiar you can't play it
the same way you played the souls games
so whether you're new to these games or
not I hope you find something here to
help you to start let's talk about the
UI the red bar is your health bar as
it's always been and it's always worth
keeping an eye on whenever you take
damage there's a couple seconds
afterwards where you can regain your
health if you strike your enemy the
amount you can potentially earn back is
signified by the light orange after the
white mark it should take you a couple
of hits to get this health back and
remember even if an enemy dies if you
continue to attack you can still get a
little bit more health back for a moment
this regain system ties into the way
that you should be playing blood-borne
most enemies are easy to stagger
depending on your weapon and depending
on their size and if you can hit them
before they hit you again take that
chance the green bar below the health
bar is your stamina and it's consumed by
most elements of your movement attacking
dodging running all of it uses stamina
and while it regenerates quickly you
should be aware of when you have none
left below the stamina bar are your
blood vials seen here and your quick
silver bullets seen here these are the
two most important parts of your
inventory blood vials are your manual
healing and are consumed with triangle
bullets are used while your gun is in
your left hand by pressing l2 guns in
this game aren't primarily used for
damage they're used to stun enemies and
if you shoot an enemy right before it
hits you you can stagger it and go in
for the critical attack by tapping r1 to
their right is the item you currently
have selected for quick access you'll
want to put your most often used
consumables here like Molotov cocktails
throwing knives or pebbles by pressing
down on the d-pad you can toggle between
the ones you have selected and you can
use square to throw them or use them to
put different items on this bar you
press the options button and you go down
to the six boxes at the
bottom another method for quick access
is your personal effects bar by clicking
in the right side of the touchpad you
pull up this bar that's best used for
not consumable items but items you use
regularly like a summoning bell or the
hunter's mark while we're in options the
row above your quick item bar is the
attire you're wearing and above that are
your weapons the two boxes on the left
in the second row are what you can
access with your right hand and the two
boxes on the right in the second row are
what you can access with your left hand
once you're in game you can switch
what's in each hand by pressing left or
right on the d-pad at the top of the
options menu we have your inventory your
player status and your settings player
status shows the details of your
particular character you'll mostly come
to this screen to check your stats which
are in the bottom left vitality
determines how much HP you have
endurance determines the length of your
green stamina bar plus your resistances
to things like poison or physical damage
strength and skill relate to how much
damage your heavy or light weapons do
respectively blood tinge relates to your
guns and arcane determines the damage
you do with elemental weapons or items
we level up by investing in these skills
using our blood echoes at the top right
of the screen we have our blood echoes
which are the currency in blood-borne we
gain blood echoes from killing our
enemies and we lose them all when we die
sometimes if you die to an enemy they
will become infused with your blood
echoes and we'll have to kill them to
get them back alternatively your echoes
could just be left behind at your point
of death you have one chance to get your
echoes back after you die and after that
they gone forever
below your echoes is your insight
counter insight is consumed whenever you
want to initiate multiplayer and allows
us to better perceive the world around
us you gather it most commonly from
encountering bosses but you can also
acquire it by consuming the item
madman's knowledge with more insight you
start seeing things
and as soon as you have one insight
point the doll in the hunters dream will
come to life every time you invest your
blood echoes in one skill you gain one
level and every time you level the next
level will cost more echoes but while
your stats matter what matters more is
your skill at playing the game a good
player can get through most of this game
without even leveling up at all so be
sure to invest in your own skills as
much as your stats so we've talked about
how to heal yourself and how to assign
items and how to level up now let's talk
about how to fight in your right hand
you hold the transformable weapon called
the trick weapon in your left you'll
likely hold the weapon that consumes
Quicksilver bullets the shoulder buttons
of your controller are devoted entirely
to the weapons in your hands r1 is your
standard attack with your right hand
weapon and pressing it continuously will
allow you to perform a combo r2 is your
heavy attack and many weapons allow you
to hold down r2 to charge your attack
and do even more damage if you sneak up
behind an enemy and charge r2 fully to
strike them you will do a lot of damage
and it will allow you to initiate a
critical backstab attack if you tap
forward on the left control stick at the
same time you press r2 you'll do a
jumping attack which is really good for
closing the distance there are so many
different moves you can do and you want
to learn what each of these moves looks
like because different attacks are
perfect for different situations if I'm
in a narrow corridor I want to use a
stab attack I don't want to hit the
walls if I'm fighting multiple enemies I
want to do a horizontal swing you have
to know your weapons move set like the
back of your hand because it determines
how you play pressing l1 transforms the
weapon you hold in your right hand
and every weapon I've found so far has a
transformable state for example take the
threaded cane its standard form is a
short sword
it's our ones in this form are a simple
swipe and it's our twos are a simple
stab when I tap l1 however I transform
the weapon into a completely different
form now it splits open and becomes a
whip the whips r1 is a fast horizontal
slash and it's r2 is a slower wider more
powerful cleave if you attack with r1 or
r2 then immediately press l1 then you'll
do a transforming attack for example I
attack with this sword with r1 then I
tap l1 initiating a transforming attack
my character puts his sword into the
hammer and simultaneously slams the
hammer down the weapon is now
transformed into a hammer and I did it
all without breaking the flow of combat
pressing l2 will fire the gun you have
in your left hand unless you have a
trick weapon that forces you to put your
gun away
for example the Kirk hammer has to be
wilted with two hands so l2 doesn't fire
your gun instead it does a huge wide
sweep with the hammer so be aware of
that because you just got a new move
most guns don't exist primarily to do
damage the ones you get at the start of
the game the pistol and the blunderbuss
they exist to stun enemies if you stun
an enemy just before they strike you
you'll knock them to their knees and be
able to initiate a repost for huge
damage by going up to them and tapping
r1 every shot consumes a quick Silver
Bullet if you run out of bullets you can
actually sacrifice health for five
temporary quick silver bullets by
pressing up on the d-pad this red number
cannot exceed five I recommend healing
yourself with triangle after you
sacrifice this health it's a good way to
convert blood vials into bullets if you
have too many blood vials moving to the
right side of the controller triangle is
your dedicated healing button as I've
mentioned pressing square allows you to
use whatever you've got assigned to your
quick bar for example throwing a Molotov
cocktail X is what you use to interact
with the environment
whenever a prompt shows up and circle is
incredibly important because it's your
Dodge button if you hold your Dodge
button down you'll start the Sprint and
consume stamina that way you lock on to
enemies by pressing down on the right
analog stick and you toggle between
enemies by pushing a direction on the
right analog stick while locked on you
revolve around that enemy and all your
attacks will go towards it also while
locked on your Dodge is a quick dash and
while you're playing unlocked your Dodge
is a roll as soon as you press the Dodge
button there's this one or two frames
where you're invincible so if you press
it at the exact moment an attack would
hit you it won't alternatively you can
just dodge out of the range of the
enemies attack the melee combat in
blood-borne has so much depth I mean
just think about all the different melee
combinations you can do now each weapon
has like four consecutive r1 swipes you
have a regular r2 attack and a charger
to attack you have jumping attacks
running attacks post dodge attacks
backstep attacks which are now
completely new not to mention you can
now press l1 and do an attack that
unlocks a whole new moveset where all
the buttons do different things and
sometimes you can press l2 to do an
attack as well there is ridiculous depth
to the melee combat system now and it
will take you a long time to master even
one weapon so this is why I recommend to
have one or two transformable weapons
that you revolve your character around
you get to know the weapon you stick
with it for a while and you'd become
better that one this game is very much
about learning from your mistakes if an
enemy kills you you've got to think
about what you could have done better
and do it better next time every enemy
has a weakness for example the brick
troll is very easy to riposte
be patient learn the timings of his
attacks and shoot him just before he
strikes you some enemies have terrible
range so extend your weapon and keep
your distance some enemies a weak to
fire so use those Molotov cocktails aim
to learn something every time you die
and come back stronger push a little
further each run and when you succeed
you'll know that that success was all
you
if you need help you can summon other
players into your world once you acquire
one insight point you'll find the
beckoning Bell in the hunters dream this
item can be used to host a multiplayer
session and draw other players into your
world who are looking to help you
drawing another player into your world
uses up an insight point so use these
sessions wisely you get that insight
point back if you successfully defeat
the boss with your assistant to set up a
private co-op match with a password go
to settings Network and password
matching both of you must set the same
password to quit core use the silencing
blank item to be alone once more for
competitive multiplayer you need to have
found the sinister resonant belt and
apparently your insight level has to be
30 or more
I don't currently have footage of this
because it's recorded before release but
as I understand you'll be able to invade
other people's games to defeat them and
earn rewards for the most part I think
it's a good idea to try and go through
the world solo because you can't invite
everyone into your game limitlessly like
you used to when you play you gotta
constantly be on the lookout for
shortcuts you got to check windows for
NPCs and also check on doors to see if
you can knock on them to talk to someone
check every nook and cranny for items to
help you and most importantly keep an
eye out for messengers lanterns when you
light one of these it serves as a
checkpoint that you can use to go to and
from the hunters dream the hunters dream
is your hub world containing headstones
that transport you to different areas of
the overworld and many things that make
your adventures into the overworld
easier when you come here you should aim
to have a lot of blood echoes to spend
you can either level up at doll or
purchase items from the messengers at
the baths but unless you absolutely need
an item like Molotov cocktails or health
files or bullets you should be investing
your blood echoes at doll because no one
can take away your investment in your
own character but consumables are just
that they're consumable you should only
buy consumables when you're having a
difficult time with some sections for
example if there's an enemy weak to fire
then grab a few Molotov cocktails if
there's a huge lumbering enemy or having
trouble with it's almost certain that
shooting him and reposting him is the
best way to take him out so bitin
bullets if you find yourself with 20
bullets or 20 blood vials which is the
maximum I seriously recommend storing
them in the storage cabinet the more you
replay a section the less items enemies
will drop and if you're seriously stuck
and you keep killing the same enemies
over and over again those enemies won't
drop blood files and bullets and that
section of the game will become even
harder so when you're having an easy
time save these important consumables
for your difficult times to come at the
upgrade table next to the fireplace you
can socket your weapons with gemstones
that you find in the world you can
upgrade it with blood stones which will
make it plus 1 plus 2 and so on making
it deal more damage or you can repair it
if it takes too much damage out in the
world I recommend you spend your blood
stones and your sockets on a weapon that
you really like don't use them sparingly
and that's the simple version of most of
the things that I think you need to know
about this game the specifics as I play
more of the game and learn about it you
should check out my dream guide where
I'm going to take you through everything
and try and help you with difficult
parts and bosses and allow you guys to
talk about your experiences as well but
thanks for watching welcome to
blood-borne